حبيت اشوف كيف ابانا وجدادنا كان يمشون في
الصحراء ولا معاي جي بي اس ولا معاي اي
شيء يدل على الاتجاهات ولا حاجه حبيت اعيش
تجربه صدق زي ما كانوا يعيشونها
[موسيقى]
الخط الاساسيه كان المفروض امشي الصباح
فقط لكن غيرت الخطه صرت امشي بالليل
والصباح استمتع بالليل بالهدوء والسكون
انا والناقه لحالنا يعني امشي اسمع اسمع
انفاس الناقه بس
[موسيقى]
احد التحديات صراحه انه سبحان الله كيف
فتره الظهريه
فتره المساء تلبس ثلاث اربع قطع فهذا شيء
ما كنت متوقع على الامانه ان درجات
الحراره كذا تتغير ولكن الحمد لله الواحد
لازم يعيش ويتعايش زي ما بانوا اجدادنا
كانوا يعيشون احنا نعيش كمان
في الصحراء كيف كان ابائنا اجدادنا ينامون
كانوا يحفرون الحفره يحفرون حفره الحفره
هذه بما يشابه كانه تحفر قبرك شعورها وانت
تحفرها مو حلو ابدا لكن لما تحفر انت تبعد
عن
الرياح فتنزل كذا على تنزل جوا الرمله
وتبعد عن الرياح فتقدر تنام دافي فهي
الطريقه اللي كانت يدفون فيها
طبعا الناس تقول انه ليش تسوي كذا هذا اول
سؤال كان يجيني لكن
فقط لازم الواحد يشوف يطلع برا منطقه
الراحه لانه ما في شيء مستحيل فحبيت انه
اشوف انه هل فعلا هو شيء صعب ولا ما هو
صعب فلما الناس تعرف انه والله فكره ان
الواحد يشوف ويجرب كفاله
وجميل الحمد لله انه برافو عليك يا بطل
بالعكس ولا احلى من تجارب هذه